in some amazing news for the cause of
social justice the famously oppressed
millionaire football player Colin
Kaepernick has inked another movie deal
Colin Kaepernick has just received a
film deal with Disney and ESPN this will
include an inability to get a first look
on movies and TV shows about anything
script and unscripted including a
documentary about his life that's on top
of the Netflix movie deal that he
already has and of course those two
things are on top of the multi-million
dollar reportedly endorsement deal that
Colin Kaepernick has with Nike all of
this after the millions that he'd
already made by 2016 a huge win no one
would have expected this on account of
of course how oppressed Colin Kaepernick
is Colin Kaepernick the greatest con man
of his generation but there are a lot of
con men these days we're in a whole
nation of con men these days and things
are not what they seem
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
nose show
[Music]
things are not what they seem we will
get to that on so many levels first
though yesterday I asked you that
president Trump wants new monuments and
I wanted to know which ones you thought
should be on the top of the list the
best answer came from M James which is
that Trump should put up a monument of
Trump on the top of the list and make it
huge and then every time that the left
complains about at the monument gets ten
feet higher and we can make Mexico pay
for it I like that idea
I really liked I hope that the president
campaigns on that hope he does it my
question for tomorrow so put your
answers in today so this works obviously
it's it's early on in her tenure but the
question is is kaylee mcenany the
greatest press secretary of all time if
so what should her nickname be let me
know things are not what they seem
speaking of Caylee mcenany actually
Caylee mcenany pointed this out during a
press briefing because over the weekend
at least half a dozen children were
killed by violence on the streets of the
United States they weren't killed by
cops they weren't you they were killed
because of the squalid conditions that
they're living in and because of the
violence that is being permitted to go
on all over the streets and the
mainstream media are not talking about
it you couldn't say their names there
are many famous career criminals whose
names you could say because of
allegations have been justice against
them some legitimate allegations some
illegitimate allegations but you
couldn't say the names of any of those
children I would bet you and the reason
for that is because of the grift here
there is no word that is more abused in
today's day and age then grifter maybe
science is another word that's abused
almost as much but grifter is this word
it's it's come into popularity over the
past few months and people use it to
impugn the motives of their political
adversaries very often the people who
are calling other people grifters are
the grift airiest people themselves
however there is a specific use of the
term grifter grifter means conman it
means as fraud it means a swindler and
there are frauds and there are swindlers
and Colin Kapernick is one example but
the whole
mainstream media political establishment
apparatus is another one there the
reason that you don't know these kids
names Haley mcenany called them out for
it
finally I didn't with this you know I
was asked probably twelve questions
about the Confederate flag this
president focused on action and I'm a
little dismayed that I didn't receive
one question on the deaths that we got
in this country this weekend I didn't
receive one question about New York City
shootings doubling for the third
straight week and over the last seven
days shooting skyrocket by a hundred
forty two percent not one question
I didn't received one question about
five children who were killed and I'll
leave you with this remark by a dad it
broke my heart a dad of an eight year
old lost in Atlanta this weekend they
say black lives matters you killed a
child she didn't do nothing to nobody
was his quote we need to be focused on
securing our streets making sure no lies
are lost because all black lives matter
that of David Dorn and that of this
eight-year-old girl thank you thank you
mic drop walks off the set this is what
makes Kaylee mcenany so good at her job
obviously she's articulate obviously she
makes our hearts go pitter-patter
obviously she's very clever but the key
here is she sees through the lies she
sees through the whole story the whole
con the whole fraud she sees right
through it cuts to the heart of it and
she waits to she knows how to how to
play a little stage craft so she gets to
the end of this long press briefing she
says okay you've all asked me a lot of
questions about Confederate flags you've
asked me questions about the symbol of a
country that hasn't existed in 150 years
that no one really cares about and not
one of you asked me about the outrageous
violence the shameful violence on our
streets all weekend you should be
ashamed of yourselves
goodbye a see you later caitli mcenany
isn't the only person realizing this she
might be one of the few people within
the political system that is
acknowledging this but people on the
streets get it you know there was a guy
who was in Atlanta Atlanta was the hub
of some of the worst violence over the
weekend and a bunch of black lives
matter supporter
were holding hands and performing their
their political rituals about the
importance of black lives matter in the
radical social movement and how we've
got to overthrow the system and blah
blah blah and this guy was off to the
side the cameras were not on him he said
hey wait a second you people are all
frauds take a listen I don't know who
committed this crime but believe me once
we find out this person will be brought
to justice
white police officer gunned it down
three blacks and injury and for Wilson
High School will be set on a fire and
every black leader every chameleon
leader will be up here black lives
matters pants up black some murdering
blacks every 32 hours since June I've
been in this town all my life I'm 56
years old I am afraid of being shot and
gunned down by a black again if this was
a white police officer shooting killing
three blacks people will be out here the
school will be on fire they won't be
coming for me I saw this white police
officer but because it's black on black
crime it is socially acceptable for
blacks not to talk to the police
it is a pulse and every 32 hours since
June blacks been murdering blacks and
y'all guys got to do a better job simple
question why is it that the mainstream
media establishment is worried about and
not just worried I mean spending all of
their air time focusing on the nine
unarmed black men who were killed by
police officers last year by the way
some cases completely defensively
because unarmed doesn't mean not
dangerous but why even say the number
were six or nine go all the way for all
the nine who were unarmed why are you
focusing on that and your privileges
those lives and you're saying that
matters but you're not privileged inge
be many many many many many more people
who are killed in other instances of
crime well it's because one fits the
narrative and one does not fit the
narrative wasn't just happening in
Rochester and Atlanta and all over the
place it was happening in Washington DC
there was an 11 year old kid 11 year old
kid killed in Washington
DC because very likely of gang violence
so this kid was they were at some kind
of event and the kid went in to get his
ear buds and a stray bullet from gang
violence outside kills him
his grandfather says this on the
demonstrations against racism and police
brutality and the killing of George
Floyd he says he agrees with some of the
protesters that the cities should use
social workers and other civilians for
some of the social services but we need
more police to put a dent in this crime
we need more police not abolish the
police not defund the police we need
more police people who are living in
crime ridden places know that of course
they do you'd have to be so disconnected
you'd have to be a liar and a fraud and
a conman to actually try to convince
people that the solution to terrible
crime in their neighborhoods is getting
rid of the police we'll get two more
frauds in one second because it's not
even just on the BLM world it's in the
virus world it's in the scientific world
it's in the Academy it's all the way up
at Harvard first though you know how
much I love rake on wireless earbuds
everybody needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds I think we all know that but
before you go dropping hundreds of
dollars on a pair you need to check out
the wireless earbuds from rake on their
newest model the everyday you twenty
five-year buds are the best ones yet
with six hours of playtime seamless
bluetooth pairing more bass and a more
compact design that gives you a nice
noise isolating fit ray cons wireless
earbuds are so comfortable they are
perfect for conference calls or binging
podcasts there they they look better
than the other ones and they you know
what I'm talking about you know there
are others out there that people have
seen before
they feel better than the other ones
they're really just a terrific product
and they are priced reasonably which
cannot be said of a lot of others now is
the time to get the latest and greatest
from Ray Khan you can get 15% off your
order at buy rake on Comm slash Knowles
that's buy rake on.com slash Knowles
canna wles for 15% off rake on wireless
earbuds buy rake on Comm slash Knowles
Cana WL
yes I think the best example that I've
seen of this discrepancy between the
reality and the narrative between the
real people telling you what they see
and the fraudsters the swindlers on the
street was this CNN clip CNN shows up
there in California CNN the the news
anchor the reporter has the big mask on
even on camera right because they they
used to not wear the mask on camera
because it's preposterous and there's no
reason to do it and you can't can barely
hear anything but then one day one of
the reporters on MSNBC got called out
for this because she was shaming other
people for not wearing masks and the guy
that she was shaming pointed out that
none of her crew was really wearing
masks so now they're wearing the masks
on camera and they're talking about how
the virus is gonna kill everybody and
even though all their predictions were
wrong this time they're gonna be right
and while they talk about this imaginary
thing that's gonna kill us all this
imaginary social phenomenon that's
destroying all of our lives a man walks
up behind her and pulls down his pants
and relieves himself the warning is that
by the end of July there is completely
filled I think what says garbage bags
down pulls down his pants and so here in
California answers the call of some new
put in place you can see very subtly the
cameraman tries to change the angle to
block this guy out there are many actual
social problems in the United States my
evidence of this of course is not even
just that people are dying in bad cities
run by Democrats coincidentally not even
that people are doing filthy things on
the street but that all of us even the
normal people are agitating for the
pulling down of monuments for the
burning of cities for obviously there
are real social problems here but the
social problems are not the ones that
the mainstream media are telling us
about the the chief problem the chief
threat to our prosperity in this country
right now is not
this virus from China I suppose that's a
threat but far more a threat than that
is the fact that we're lighting our
whole country on fire and killing lots
of people and egging it all on very
different things the celebrities Matthew
McConaughey who I actually generally
like but he's wrong about this too he
doesn't want us to talk about the
killings in Chicago or Atlanta or New
York crime rates spiking going through
the roof 40 million people being thrown
out of jobs tearing down our history
tearing down our monuments hating our
own country becoming the laughingstock
of the world I don't want to talk about
any of that he just wants you to wear
your damn mask happy 240 4th birthday
America ho wait we just going through
some growing pains in this one not me
yes sir yes ma'am it is hotter and more
ways than one but growing pains are a
good thing because how the hell else
were we gonna grow up I think we've
gotta look each other in the eye I think
we got to look ourselves in the eye we
gotta look in the mirror and ask
ourselves how can I be better I can
expect more of myself another's how can
I be real more responsible how can I
have more compassion how can I have more
courage how can I be more fair how do I
make sure I wear the damn mask we
individually make these changes that's
how we make a collective change I love
Matthew McConaughey cause he's a weird
guy
leave comes off kind of weird and
usually as though he's just had a couple
puffs on that old Peruvian parsley every
so often but that line that drives me
crazy is where the damn mask right
because wear the damn mask is not saying
I need to change something about myself
maybe he's trying to phrase the sentence
that way but the sentiment of where the
damn mask is to you it's to shame
everybody else for not wearing the mask
the mask which by the way we were all
told for weeks don't wear it's not
effective it's not good to wear a mask
you can then look at some of the science
that the CDC has posted some of the
papers there is very little evidence
that the cloth masks do anything much
less your bandana that you think is
going to save you from the virus very
little scientific evidence
that this mitigates the virus at all the
in fact I would I would bet if you're
one of the people who thinks that the
mask is the most important thing we can
do to fix our country right now you are
basing that not on some scientific study
not even on historical experience in
common sense you're basing it on some
like stupid meme that you saw on Twitter
that shows or some meme that you saw on
CNN that shows that you know air doesn't
go through masks air goes through cloth
I assure you I promise you it does that
that is not the biggest issue where the
masks don't wear the masks that you know
it doesn't really bother me what you do
either way but this idea that that the
mask is the most important thing is an
attempt to distract you from a swindle
that is going on they have shut down our
country they have shut down much of our
political process we are in a
presidential election year we're not
allowed to have a campaign Joe Biden has
told us he's not going to campaign he's
gonna use that to try to get out of the
debates they're trying to shut down
Trump rallies they're trying to shut
down your ability to vote anyone noticed
that they're trying to pass this the
this massive mail-in ballot legislation
throughout many states meaning that
everybody goes and gets about a ballot
even if you do show up to the polling
station there will still be all of these
mail-in ballots out there which can be
harvested in some states legally in
California now it says what party you're
in on the outside of the envelope wonder
what's going to happen to the Republican
envelopes to say nothing of the killing
in the mayhem going on all around the
country and and they have actually
managed to convince you these con
artists these frauds have convinced you
that the most important thing is to get
some suburban housewife to put a
bandanna around her face are you kidding
me and we're falling for it we're all
falling for it and then the best one
this was my favorite one all day Harvard
University has become a correspondence
college the kids are not going to go to
school they're gonna stay home and log
on to their computer but they're not
gonna lower the tuition not one penny
it's still gonna cost you 50 grand a
year we'll get to that one second first
I got to thank our friends Oh
over at Rock Auto you know talk about
swindles when I go into the
brick-and-mortar car parts store one I
don't know that much about cars so I'm
very easy to be swindled in that
particular situation but also what do
they do you going to the car parts store
it they don't have the part for your car
so then they have to order it online
they probably go to rockauto.com they
get it in they charge you twice as much
don't do that why would you do that when
you can go to rockauto.com much easier
than walking into a store you know it
when you walk into the store and you say
okay I need this part they'll say is
your is your Odyssey and LX or an EXO
I'll say I don't know what my Odyssey is
I don't know e^x ll what do I need that
for the one thing I love about rock Auto
well there many things I love one in
particular is that even I can navigate
the website even I can find car parts
the other thing I love is it's family on
business they've been serving car parts
customers online for 20 years which is
pretty much the entirety that online
businesses have existed
head on over reliable prices no gimmicks
what-you-see-is-what-you-get
rockauto.com go there right now you can
see all the parts available for your car
or truck right Knolls kena wles in there
how did you hear about us box so that
they know that we sent you Javed Javed
is now a correspondence college it's an
online school it's the University of
Phoenix except it costs five or six
times as much
the thing about McConaughey and wear the
mask one reason that it works is that
you feel like you got to be in the club
you feel the social pressure to be part
of the same club that everybody's in and
so you put the mask on even if you don't
think it's very effective that's the
same thing with Harvard that's the same
thing with the elite universities what
they're selling you is not primarily an
education what they are selling you
primarily is a credential into the elite
a very particular liberal elite but
still an elite that will increase your
chances of getting a lucrative job in
finance or consulting and having a
basically lucrative career
- moving yourself up maybe into the
middle class or the upper middle class
or even higher
that is the value proposition of Harvard
and so it is no surprise that when
Harvard decides to go online and you
don't get to go to Harvard Yard and you
don't get to be around the beautiful
campus somewhat beautiful campus and you
don't get to network with people you
just go be online you'll still pay
almost 50 grand a year I think the
annual tuition is forty-nine thousand
six hundred fifty three dollars some
people think that this is a ripoff so
some people don't quite understand how
this elite university system works and
they think that the thing that makes it
so bad is that it's expensive and it's a
ripoff and you go into debt it's
actually worse than that because the way
that this works is not that you it's a
ripoff to go to one of these schools if
it's a very elite brand-name college and
then you leave with a lot of debt you
actually don't leave with debt the thing
where these schools is their endowments
is so low are so large that if you can't
afford to go there you just go for free
or you go for very very cheap that's not
the issue
Harvard makes its money from alumni
doesn't make its money mostly from
students that half the students pay to
go there and about half are on
significant financial aid the thing
that's so shocking about Harvard is not
that the 49 $50,000 tuition is is not
worth it it's that it is worth it it's
worth it for the networking it's worth
it for the credential it's worth it if
you want to go into a handful of fields
that are being pushed by the system
consulting finance that sort of thing
the only way it's not worth it is if you
want to get an education that's the
crazy part is it's a university but
they're not primarily giving you an
education of course the evidence of this
that if if you radically change the
educational experience but you don't
reduce the price then the thing that
you're pricing out is not the education
it's this elite this system that is
propagating itself that pretends to be a
university
but that won't teach you a very very
many things I mean the great example
just a few years ago Yale decided to
take the Shakespeare requirement out of
its English major you can graduate with
a degree summa [ __ ] laude top honors in
English from Yale and not read
Shakespeare or Chaucer well what's the
value of that education the degree is
worth a lot because it buys your way
into the system the education not quite
as much what it means about Harvard is
the Diploma is just as valuable as a
letter of admission but actually the
experience of being there doesn't matter
as much at all and that is a sort of
swindle that is a sort of con but what
are we focusing on or focusing on or not
actual structural issues in the country
what we're focusing on is the same
ginned up contrived racial division that
we see sometimes at sexual divisions
sometimes it's racial division but it's
always the same kind of predictable
political paths Cayley mcenany be still
our beating hearts Haley mcenany again
that a press briefing this was now two
or three days ago she was asked about
the the comment the President Roh made
about black lives matter organization
being a sort of hateful symbol the thing
that struck me about this is the thing
about systems Harvard right all of these
credentialing systems the thing about
systems is that they're systematized
they're organized and black lives matter
place its role - black lives matter is
not about black lives matter obviously
it's it's a it's an organization with
leadership that describes itself as
trained Marxists that sets up these
contrived protests protests
quote-unquote city-by-city it's a show
it's a shell game here is K Lee's answer
why is the president calling black lives
matter a simple
well what the president was noting is
that that symbol when you look at some
of the things that have been chanted by
black lives matter like pigs in a
blanket for I am like bacon that's not
an acceptable phrase to paint on our
streets look he agrees that all black
lives matter including that of officer
David Dorn
Patrick underwood to officers whose
lives were tragically taken amid these
riots all black lives do matter he
agrees with that sentiment but what he
doesn't agree with is an organization
the chance pigs in a blanket fry him
like bacon about our police officers our
valiant heroes who are out on the street
protecting us each and every day
yeah I think this is a pretty good
answer i I do wish that we didn't even
have to do this thing of saying yes of
course we agree black lives matter
because yet listen Jon Karl I don't owe
you an explanation of thinking that
human beings ought to be able to live
innocent human beings I don't owe you
that premise I doubt you know I wish we
anyone have to take the the bait of hey
do you still be your wife of course the
president doesn't still beat his wife
but the issue you know I wish we didn't
even have to do that maybe though in our
mainstream system if you're if you're
talking to these reporters maybe you
have to I prefer if we didn't have to
but then Jon Karl pushes it and Kaylie
lays the smackdown protested in all 50
states around that phrase black lives
matter and the president is here calling
it a symbol of hate he's talking about
the organization
I would note to you that the Greater New
York BLM president has said if this
country doesn't give us what we want
that we will burn down the system and I
could be speaking literally I'd call
that a pretty hateful statement yes the
organization is tweety says yes this is
the word black lives what's the name of
the organization again black lives
matter there you go answer my question
go ahead Ben no it's just the words come
on and write what what is the name of
the organization it's the words that
you're talking about it's so transparent
what this guy is doing it's so
transparent what the rest of them are
doing it this is the thing that bugs me
I mean there are a lot of things to bug
me about about this whole fraud that
we're being exposed to right now but but
among them is
predictable at all is it's just so
contrived I mean even then it black
lives matter you've got an organization
that seeks to destroy the Western
prescribed to nuclear family
quote-unquote an organization that seeks
to abolish the police tear down our
entire history radically transformed the
country refers to each other as comrades
and admits that they're trained Marxists
but if you don't go along with that
radical insane organization then that
means you hate black people it's just so
lame it's so contrived I don't want to
give it a moment's notice but this is
what happens you've got these
organizations they know what they're
doing they've they've been here before
they've played this game before and then
what they will do is every so often when
things start to die down they'll pick
some random incident that is completely
without any context and they'll use that
as an example of some broad trend of
hatred and bigotry and start the whole
game over again we saw that just
yesterday at the sandwich shop Jimmy
John's which we'll get to in one second
first though got to thank our friends
over at blinks ale
you should not waste your time creating
ugly invoices on your computer you
should not one because it's a waste of
time too because you're better than that
you don't come on don't do that with
blink sale you can send beautiful custom
branded invoices and estimates in
seconds staying on top of your
outstanding invoices let your customers
and clients easily pay your invoices
online you will even get instant
notifications when a customer opens up
your invoice so that you will actually
know if they are just trying not to pay
you blink sale takes care of it all
so you can spend more time focusing on
the work that actually gets you paid and
makes your business a success as an
added bonus bling sale is now giving
away 10 to 5 10 dollars not not 10 to 10
dollars to 500 daily wire fans here is
how you get it go to bling sale comm
start your 14-day free trial
create your first invoice of $10 and
activate an online payment options
stripe or PayPal you send the invoice to
daily wire at blink sale comm you will
get paid your $10 the first 500 people
to send an invoice for $10 to daily wire
at bling sale comm will get their
invoice paid by bling sale this is
pretty good
of one of these per person stop wasting
your time in voicing trembling seal for
free right now bli nks al e comm /
Knowles blink sale spend less time
billing more time doing what you love so
predictable so predictable these
incidents I think at this point the
these power structures that be could
just pick one up out of nowhere
completely contrived it out of nothing
and whip America up into a national
frenzy that's more or less what they did
at Jimmy John's Jimmy John's is a chain
sandwich shop it's very good sandwich
shop
I like Jimmy John's a lot there was a
video it went viral of some bored Jimmy
John's employees playing with the dough
for the bread my first job was as a
Subway sandwich artist so I I have
played with this kind of dough for the
bread before and what they did is they
wrapped the the dough around the rest of
the dough and they made a noose for it
these were all white employees by the
way and then one of the one of the
employees puts the dough noose on his
neck and he's like you know kind of
pretending to his tongue hanging out and
they take a picture of it and that's it
might make you worry about the
cleanliness of this particular Jimmy
John's establishment but whatever it's
just a funny little joke right
wrong oh this this got Jimmy John's to
trend on Twitter these guys lives
probably gonna be destroyed because
don't you know that nooses are a
universally racist symbol against black
people now that's not true of course but
that is the narrative that the left is
telling you of course that's not true
nooses have been used throughout all of
human history nooses go back to Homer to
the Bible to it like as long as we have
a history of humanity there have been
nooses but even in more recent times
when you think of the news in America do
you immediately exclusively go to
anti-black lynching no I think the most
common use of a noose in America is
suicide
we have a suicide epidemic in this
country that's a real problem in this
country black people do not get lynched
it doesn't happen if you want
back the last 30 years maybe you would
find one example of that in the whole
country one or two probably just one
though if you went back 150 years you'd
probably find some examples or I guess I
suppose we've been a 130 years or that
that then you could definitely find
examples but today in this country right
now could you know you'd find a lot of
examples though of people killing
themselves because of social and
political and economic conditions
psychological conditions national
madness but that's a real problem so you
have to be distracted away from that by
frauds and put onto this imagined
problem right now in this country if you
were to think of the nuisance in the
broader context of American history
would you necessarily think of
anti-black lynchings which did occur or
would you think of regular old Criminal
Justice like real criminal justice in
for instance the Wild West every Western
ever practically is had nooses in them
the hangman's noose when our republic
was founded the the punishment for a
felony was hanging everywhere he was
much more frequently there even on the
specific topic of lynching lynching was
not exclusively anti-black the largest
mass lynching in American history was
perpetrated against Italian people I
know this a little bit because I happen
to be of Italian extraction and actually
it was that large lynching of 11 people
at one time some of whom were killed by
hanging that prompted the following year
the formation of Columbus Day 400 years
after the Admiral of the ocean say
sailed the ocean blue and that day
obviously now is trying to be overturned
by the radicals there is no way to look
at this Jimmy John's video and say this
is a clear example of anti black racism
and bigotry was an anti black joke I
liked maybe but probably not
I bet it wasn't but that's the imaginary
focus over the real problems in the
country goes all the way down to other
universities could it even affects the
conservative side of the
kalila I'm sorry to say which we'll get
to in one second first though thank you
so much for subscribing to the Michael
Nolt show and Apple podcast if you
haven't done that already please do we
appreciate that you can head over there
if you subscribe leave five star review
that really helps us out
thank you for going over the Michael
null show you tube channel not the daily
wire YouTube channel but the Michael
Knoll show YouTube channel where we have
exclusive content which includes I just
chatted with my friend charlie kirk it's
Charlie Kirk is the founder of
turning-point we talked about this new
Kanye run for president because it
occurred to me that Charlie Kirk is one
of two people I know who has hung out
extensively with both Kanye and the
president that's Charlie and Candace
Owens is the to two friends of mine
who've hung out with both of those guys
so you can check that h.a on my
interview with Dave Rubin and also get a
reader's pass at daily wire $0.99 for
your first month three bucks a month
after that you get access to our mobile
app articles ad free you get lots of
election insight editorials that you
wouldn't get otherwise head on over
Daley wire.com and finally get Ben's
book Ben's got a new book obviously
there's a ton of leftist media spin
going on a lot of division a lot of
fraud in this country right now well Ben
talks about all this stuff in his new
book how to destroy America in three
easy steps
pre-order your signed copy of daily
wire.com slash Ben get your copy today
head on over to the le wired I come over
right back
the distractions will go on and on until
we stop them
and it's very hard to slow this stuff
down okay it has a momentum of its own
this thing about the system Harvard and
the press and Hollywood and right way
we've touched on all those guys already
Hollywood gives Colin Kapernick the
movie deal and the press pushes all the
questions that the movie deal is premise
done and Harvard maintains its
credentialing system to keep people in
and out of the elite and this goes
through all of the institutions of our
country such that it's very hard to
crack even down at the University of
Memphis University of Memphis football
team has just announced its coaches just
announced Ryan silver field that the
team will wear black lives matter
stickers on their helmets this season
this will be the first d1 football team
to do that and the stickers will read in
part hash tag all in against racial
injustice raise your hand I know you're
in the privacy of your own cars or your
own homes right now maybe you're walking
down the streets this will look a little
weird but I want you to raise your hand
if you are for racial injustice raise
your hand anything I'm gonna close my
eyes I'm gonna imagine the whole
audience I would bet nobody raised their
hand not one person not one single
person I bet if you polled the whole
country 330 million people maybe you'd
get like two or three crazy people who
raised their hands I think that's about
it I don't think anybody is for racial
injustice but you got to pretend you got
to pretend that's part of the system
maybe these student athletes could talk
about how they're being treated how
they're being treated like workers but
they're not being given the protections
of workers no no that's a real problem
that's an actual issue so you got to
distract from that maybe these student
athletes could talk about how they're
not receiving an actual education and
they're just being used as pawns to make
money for a university and more largely
for a system no no that's a real problem
got to distract from that hey pay no
attention to that follow
the card follow the shell game look over
here look at the sparkly object are you
are you for racial injustice no but I'm
now I'm so worried I got to put the put
the sticker on my helmet a big gap here
between the reality and the illusion
this even affects the right by the way
mostly affects the left but it affects
the right - so the way these intersected
yesterday this was another trend on
social media I rammed you know I ran she
was this novelist in the 20th century
she created the philosophy or ideology
called objectivism and the whole thing
is sort of greed is good
selfishness is good sure a famous essay
called the virtue of selfishness which
is what it sounds like some
conservatives kind of like her mostly
libertarians kind of liked her a little
bit so I mean she wrote Atlas Shrugged
she wrote The Fountainhead these books
that are about 7,000 pages too long I'm
not a huge fan of iron Rand I was when I
was 17 just like all 17 year olds are
but then I am no longer a huge fan of
hers anyway she was trending yesterday
because the iron Rand Institute which is
all premise done selfishness and not
relying on anybody and make your own
make your own money support yourself it
turns out they took a loan from the
federal government from the Small
Business Association to keep their
workers employed during the coronavirus
lockdown I think that's perfectly
defensible I don't think it's terribly
hypocritical but this was trending as a
big dunk on conservatives haha those
conservatives their philosophy doesn't
make any sense because look at what
hypocrites they are they took money from
the government even though they hate
money from the government and what
occurred to me when I saw an Rand
trending as the representative of the
conservative movement such as it is is
even our political opposition is
contrived along the left's lines the
left is even defining what it means to
oppose the left because I think if you
polled a hundred conservatives and you
said is ein Rand your greatest hero I
think most of them would say I knew
what's a nine Rand and I think for the
people who did know 98 or 99 out of 100
wouldn't care
much for her iana and was written out of
the conservative movement sixty years
ago in 1957 Whittaker Chambers who's the
great anti-communist author of witness
he wrote a scathing review of her book
in National Review Bill Buckley who in
many ways led the conservative movement
led to Reaganism he followed that up in
National Review he said Iran's exclusion
from the conservative community was I am
sure in part the result of her
dessicated philosophies conclusive
incompatibility with the Conservatives
emphasis on transcendence intellectual
and moral but also there is the
incongruity of tone that hard schematic
implacable unyielding dogmatism that is
in itself intrinsically objectionable
whether it comes from the mouth of
Ehrenberg or Savonarola or eine ram this
idea that Iran she had no moral compass
she was she was fanatically atheist she
couldn't understand how any smart person
could believe in God her moral order
didn't make any sense it was all about
greed is good and it was it was all
about progress right it was all about
ugly aesthetics it was just is not
conservative whatever you think of it it
wasn't conservative but the left has
defined ein Rand that's kind of the
great example of what a conservative is
because they can't deal with the reality
of what a conservative is what the left
permits what the system permits is for
there to be I call them court jester
conservatives they're a little foil in
the court of liberalism that offers some
sort of slightly different point of view
usually doesn't disagree too much with
the premises of the left and then loses
gracefully and then when they lose
gracefully it legitimizes the whole
liberal system even much of our
political opposition is a fraud no no
where do you see this more clearly then
the two remaining never Trump errs you
know I'm talking about the guys over at
the Lincoln project the Lincoln project
which in itself is a huge grift it's a
huge lie the the Lincoln project is an
anti-trump group of Republicans the
former Republicans but what's notable
about them is they're not ex politicians
or office holders or great thinkers
mostly it's just political consultants
old campaign
flaks who had cinah cures who had who
had very lucrative careers that Trump
destroyed because he didn't hire any of
them and when he didn't hire any of them
they got extremely frustrated that they
lost their gigs and so they without any
principles whatsoever decided to oppose
him I think maybe there one or two
people that have any principles in that
whole group but I doubt it I think I'm
being overly generous I think they're
cynical I think they're con men and
here's how I know they're con men they
lie so they posted this clip of Donald
Trump talking about a military conflict
and this went viral because it sounded
as though the president thought that
Operation Desert Storm which occurred in
Iraq actually occurred in Vietnam they
carried American warriors into the dense
fields and jungles of Vietnam they
delivered a swift and swoop in you know
that sweeping it was Swift and it was
sleeping like nobody's ever seen
anything happened a victory and
Operation Desert Storm okay so he
stumbled on the teleprompter he meant to
say Swift and sweeping but he got caught
up in that so that sounds a little weird
say it happens to everybody who uses
teleprompters at some point or another
you will get caught up on a word I say I
admit this is just my secret with you
it's even happened to me once or twice
so it happened to Trump but did Trump
really think that Operation Desert Storm
occurred in the jungles of Vietnam no
groups like the Lincoln project edited
the video edited out the relevant
context just 15-20 seconds before where
he says he's not just talking about
Vietnam he's talking about major
American conflicts here it is just this
is about 20 seconds before in a few
moments we will bear witness to awesome
aircraft representing every major
military conflict over the last 75 years
okay every major military conflict over
the past 75 years it's very obvious what
he's saying but because they can't get
him on the facts they've got to edit it
they've got and this is what happens I
mean I think the the selectively edited
phenomenon is funny because the
always refers to are perfectly
legitimate videos as selectively edited
we you could get a Planned Parenthood
official on camera saying I am haggling
with you for baby Parts I want to buy a
Lamborghini which we actually have and
they'll say that was selectively edited
you say how could you selectively edit
that it's nothing that the issue isn't
the edit the issue are the words that
you're saying they'll say that's
selectively edit it and then they will
actually selectively edit out relevant
context from our videos and they'll
forget about it
that is they'll try to get you to forget
about it that is the way this system
works top political issue of the day so
important I found this out from Jezebel
and then this too was going all around
the internet Halle Berry a very talented
actress might play a trans man what is a
trans man a trans man is a woman who
thinks that she's a man so Halle Berry
an actress might pretend to be somebody
who she is not which is I believed last
time I checked that's what actors do and
actresses
moreover Halle Berry an actress will
pretend to be another woman pretending
to be a man but when a woman pretends to
be a man in reality that is sacred that
is wonderful and few question that
you're a bigot but when an actress
pretends to be another woman on the
stage which is her job that is evil and
terrible and wrong that is our
upside-down culture that we're in I mean
they go and they say Halle Berry is
either ignoring or is it not gotten the
message that trans characters should be
played by trans actors but she has quite
a few civ a better wish to play a trans
man in an upcoming project so so trans
characters should be played by people
who want to pretend to be other things
not by actresses who by definition
pretend to be other things I see
Scarlett Johansson's experience has
taught her nothing and that was two
years ago Scarlett Johansson got caught
in some trouble with this because a few
years ago she also wanted to play a part
of someone who is confused about his his
or her gender and but listen to the
threat there Scarlett Johansson's
experience has taught her nothing
it's this pressure look what we did
Scarlett Johansson will do it to you you
got to stop it
you got to go along with the system
whatever it says you even saw this I
think most notably though this is far
less sexy kind of story
highlighting this but I think it's
probably actually the most important one
from the Supreme Court Supreme Court
yesterday there was a case that came out
Kia fellow versus Washington this was a
case about whether or not states can
punish electors who do not vote for the
presidential candidates that they say
they're gonna vote for you know in our
system we don't have a popular election
we don't we don't just all the people go
out and vote and then whoever has the
most votes wins thankfully we don't have
that 2016 - mm good good thing we don't
have that what we have is a system that
our founders set up called the electoral
college and so what happens is you go
out in your state and you vote and then
you vote for electors and then the
electors come up obvious you've all the
the ballot for whomever Trump or Clinton
you know Trump or Biden but then really
what you're electing or electors who
have pledged to vote for those people
but the founders crucially set up a
system whereby the electors can then go
to cast their votes and vote for
whomever they would like because we have
independent electors this was one of the
compromises to cut to deal with this
problem of mob rule what if there's a
really really bad man or woman Hillary
Clinton who is up for the job and the
electors want to override the will of
the mob you know there's good democracy
in this and then there's mob rule we
don't we want the good stuff we don't
want the bad stuff clearly that was the
point of this provision in the
Constitution the point was that the
electors should be independent and yet
in a unanimous decision yesterday the
Supreme Court judges voted to allow
states to punish the electors that
they're called faithless electors
electors who don't vote for the people
they say they're gonna vote for even the
original ists went along with this -
albeit for different reasons than the
Liberals did why why was it unanimous
well I think it's a perfectly perfectly
fine thing to do to make the electors
vote for the people they say they're
going to vote for it's been happening in
this country since almost the very
beginning
and that's what they cite they say it's
long-standing practice that they are
expected to do this kind of thing but
it's not in in the Constitution we know
that's not the point of the Constitution
and the point of this provision even the
original lists admit it's not really
about it's not really about that what
this shows us is that there is a written
constitution and then there is the
actual Constitution that we live under
the constitution of experience and
tradition and practice that can be a
good thing that can be a bad thing does
it that's the reality that's the reality
of how countries are governed countries
are actually not governed by sheets of
paper that were written hundreds of
years ago they're really governed by
this sort of practice we might wish that
we were governed by the sheet of paper
many ways I wish we were but we're not
the sooner we shake ourselves out of
that delusion the sooner we will be able
to fight back and actually get some
cultural political economic wins okay
the sooner we realize the con that is
being perpetrated whether it's at this
very lofty esoteric sort of level of the
constitutional interpretation or whether
it's the actual product being peddled by
Harvard or whether it's Colin freakin
Kaepernick who still with a straight
face pretends to be an oppressed
aggrieved victim as he cashes in
millions and millions and millions all
the way to the bank way more than he
would have made in football the sooner
we wake up to that the con that's being
perpetrated on us the sooner that we
will be able to exercise a little bit of
power ourselves that's our show I'm
Michael no listen Michael no show as see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders
hair and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the ben
shapiro show we'll get a whole lot of
that and much more see you there